A farmer grows 531 tomatoes
and is able to sell 176 of them
in three days, so is able to
sell 176 of them in three days.
Given that his supply of
tomatoes decreases by 176,
how many tomatoes
does he have remaining
at the end of three days?
So he starts with 531 tomatoes.
Let me give myself a little
bit more space to work with.
He starts with 531 tomatoes,
and he's able to sell 176.
So he's essentially going to
subtract the 176 that he's
selling if we want to figure
out how many he's left with.
So we're going to subtract 176.
That's how many he
sells in three days.
And they're asking
us, how much does
he have left at the
end of three days?
We just have to subtract
those 176 from the amount
that he grew.
So it turns into this
straight-up subtraction
problem, so let's
see if we can do it.
So if we go straight
to the ones place
right over here--
and actually, let
me do it in parallel,
because I think
that might be
interesting over here.
I'm going to do it the way
you traditionally do it
here on the left,
and then I'm going
to show you what's happening
over here on the right.
So 531 is the same thing
as 500 plus 30 plus 1.
And if you subtract 176,
that's the same thing
as subtracting 100,
subtracting another 70,
and subtracting another 6.
And I wrote it this way,
because the 5 in 531
is the same thing as 500.
The 3 in 531 is
in the tens place,
so it's really representing 30.
The 1 in 531 is in the ones
place, so it represents 1.
And now it'll be a
little bit clearer
what we're doing when we're
borrowing or regrouping
on this problem right over here.
And so let's start off
with the ones place.
1 is less than 6.
It'd be great if we can
regroup some of the value
from the rest of the places
so we could go straight
to the tens place.
The tens place, we can
borrow or regroup 10 from it.
So if we take 10 from
here, this becomes 20.
We're going to take that
10 and add it to the 1,
so this will become 11.
We just added 10.
We moved over 10 from the
tens place to the ones place.
If you look at it over
here, you could say, look,
we're taking 10 from the 30.
That becomes a 20, and
then the 1 becomes an 11.
The way when I was first in
school, people would say you
would borrow 1 from the 3.
And you'd kind of just stick
that 1 right over here.
But what you're really doing
is you're taking a 10 from a 30
and making it into a 20, and
you're adding that 10 to the 1
and getting 11.
But either way, you'll end
up with 11 in the ones place.
And now you can subtract.
11 minus 6 is 5.
Now we go over to
the tens place.
In the tens place we
now have 2 minus 7,
which is really
representing 20 minus 7.
Well, that 70 is
bigger than 20, so we
want to add some more
to the tens place.
Well, we could go to
the hundreds place
to find some more
value to regroup.
So let's see if we can do that.
We have 500 here.
What happens if we
take 100 from that?
So we're just left
with 400 here.
And we take that 100, and
we put it in the tens place.
So instead of 20,
we now have 120.
If you look at it
on this problem,
since we're using
the places here,
we're going to take 100
from the 500 and have 400.
And then we're going
to take that 100
that we took and put
it to the tens place.
Well, 100 is 10 tens.
So we're going to
add 10 to this,
so this is going to become a 12.
Once again, the more
mechanical or rote way
of thinking about it is that,
oh, you took 1 away from the 4.
And you stick that 1
onto the front of the 2.
But you're really taking 100
from the 500 to make it 400
and then adding that 100 to
the 20 here and making it 120.
But you write it here as
a 12 because it's 12 tens.
You're in the tens place.
Let me write it down.
This is the ones place.
This is the tens place, and
this is the hundreds place.
So now that our number
on top in the tens place
is bigger than our number on
the bottom, we can subtract.
So we get 120 minus 70.
That is 50, or 12 minus 7 is 5.
But that 5 is in the tens place,
so it's really representing 50.
Let me circle it
with the same color
so you recognize that
this 5 is representing 50.
Then finally, we're
in the hundreds place.
400 minus 100 is 300.
4 minus 1 is 3, but
this 3 represents 300.
This 5 represents 50.
This 5 represents 5,
and so we're done.
We get 355.
The farmer is left
with 355 tomatoes
at the end of three days, or
300 plus 50 plus 5 tomatoes.